so der unterricht hat angefangen jetzt
leise hier nagel lehrerin ist wieder da
[Musik]
ein bisschen geboren ein bisschen
stimmung
stimmung jetzt wo ich das hier so sehr
in rage insgesamt ausführlich sag mal
eine gute sieben von zehn ja aber das
make up
das konnte ring
heute gegen das video online und die
kommentare haben wir wieder gezeigt dass
auch ich ein arrogantes stück scheiße
sein kann es tut mir leid falls sich
jemand verletzt gefühlt hat durch die
art wie ich kann den kalender erwartet
habe es ist eine explosive mischung aus
ich habe viele ganz kalender auszupacken
und sehr wenig zeit dadurch bin ich
vielleicht ganz schön hart gewesen aber
mir tut es wirklich leid ich verstehe
den punkt dass ich vielleicht schon
selbst gemacht hat man's kann da nicht
so hart bewerten sollte was den preis
angeht weil dann natürlich viel arbeit
hinter steck ich hoffe ihr könnt mir
verzeihen die sich angegriffen gefühlt
haben und wir machen ganz fröhlich
weiter deswegen gibt es heute ein ganz
braven look von mir guck mal ich bin ich
bin ein land bin ein wolf im schafspelz
ich bin ein lamm im wolfspelz manchmal
und damit mein image natürlich wieder
müssen aufpoliert wird habe ich ein ganz
toller grenz kalender mitgebracht den
adventskalender
nicht tatsächlich wollte ich den er
heute auspacken immer wenn ich von einem
zuschlag bekommen habe welchen
adventskalender noch auspacken soll habe
ich mir den angeguckt und dachte mir ja
gut den beständig und anni hat mich dann
immer darauf gewartet meinte wie viele
hast du jetzt sondern weiß also vier
liegen schon mal hier es war glaube ich
im september und 10 werden noch
geliefert der adventskalender ist einer
davon den kann man immer sehr früh
vorbestellen und der wird dann ab mitte
oktober glaube ich geliefert deswegen
packe ich den erst jetzt aus ich glaube
ich habe den ende oktober bekommen und
er sieht dieses jahr mal wieder
fantastisch aus weiß nicht ob ihr schon
den letzten advent zum adventskalender
bei mir gesehen habt ich habe geheult
weil er tatsächlich so berühren war es
mir die tränen kamen
geld zu haben sich viele aus dem
öffentlichen leben zurück vereinsamen
dieses jahr werde ich aber meine tränen
zurückhalten
außer es ist wieder etwas von ein herz
für rentner drin dann kann ich für
nichts garantieren das besondere an
adventskalendern ist dass die soziale
projekte unterstützen und auch die
füllungen sind vegan
nachhaltig start up produkte die gerade
irgendwie cool sind also eine bunte
mischung aus eigentlich freue mich drauf
es werden bestimmt wieder super leckere
snacks drin sein und wir gucken uns noch
ganz kurz vorher karte an also hier
super adventszeit
[Applaus]
jetzt noch mal
sind die schüler dieses design dieses
jahr muss endlich ein bisschen an hätte
man kriegt noch drei postkarten sehr
sehr schön und man sonst bleibt ihr
nichts weiteres zu sagen als dieses
videos mich gesponsert und jetzt alle
dieses videos nicht gespart doch bevor
wir hier irgendetwas machen natürlich
wollen wir den preis wissen dieses jahr
kostete hat wenn es keinen nach 119 euro
ein happiger preis auf jeden fall aber
wir schauen mal was wiederum so finden
hier wird schon mal ein paar umschläge
mit zahlen drauf die haben wir wunderbar
selbst verpackte pakete total niedlich
ich finde das auch superschön und simpel
einfach in seidenpapier und geblieben
nachdem es die adventskalender ich habe
wirklich merken wir jetzt mein hirn
jedes wort überlegt was ich gerade
gesagt ich weiß ist ein bisschen
übertrieben aber wenn man in der
öffentlichkeit steht dann das hat echt
schwierig manchmal meint ja nicht
wirklich böse oder will absichtlich
leute verletzen aber dann tut man das
irgendwie dann ja ich wurde tatsächlich
hart kritisiert dass ich hart kritisiert
habe mist
ich bin ehrlich mit euch box riecht nach
einer guten foto machen richtig schön
limette reingemacht hat sie richtig hier
nochmal eins natürlich noch mal eins ist
veganer bio lebkuchen aus nürnberg sie
aus dem keller pizzakarton
pizza kartons und hier ist eine kennerin
die verpackung macht mich fertig die
verpasst ist ja so süß gestaltet
[Musik]
seid ihr eigentlich team vor der
weihnachtszeit schon
weihnachtssüßigkeiten essen oder er ist
in der weihnachtszeit dann auf jeden
fall team vorher weihnachtszeit
da sind nicht mit so einem supermarkt
produkt zu vergleichen also weihnachten
in deine fresse sehr sehr lecker
bierchen damals war ich würde vermuten
eine kerze bei der form
nein mit night magic natürlich nummer 2
befindet sich eine reichhaltige
nachtcreme in biologisch abbaubaren
titels ist biologisch abbaubar
absolut neutral ich rieche nichts ein
warum für jedes bestellte produkt ja ist
naturkosmetik assistieren berliner
startup und es setzt auf nachhaltigkeit
werde die creme nicht anfassen damit ich
sie verlosen kann weil ich drei nacht
krems gerade im badezimmer stehen habe
und irgendwann ist auch mal nie bloss 30
bin nicht ganz sicher aber damit ist
schon gemeint hier drei plus eins also
natürlich in vielen da muss ja guten
abend zu einer erneuten sondersendung
bevor ich verdiene ich verlor sie euch
ein ihr könnten anwender sind können
gewinnen aber es könnte sein dass ich
ihn schon auf insgesamt verlost hat wenn
das jetzt online geht ich bin mir aber
nicht sicher und wenn es nicht so ist
dann kommt jetzt die verlosung para ich
lege mir die pakete hier aus ist kann
nicht immer sagen dass sie 3 jetzt
hatten wir letztes jahr schon drin oder
ja doch
ein gutes ja das hat mir letztes jahr in
ein kuschel hand tatsächlich heißt die
marke auch kuschel unglaublich
kuscheliges gäste handtuch aus hall
kuschel pflanzt pro handtuch zwei bäume
ist weltweit die erste klima ressourcen
positive textil marke das fühlt sich
super an das handtuch und das ist ein
tolles gestern hoch und es ist grün in
der weihnachtszeit willkommen zu unserem
ersten umschlag wie haben einen brief
gekriegt sie haben ein brief gekriegt
ich hab' ich muss nicht heulen
es ist ein alter mann auf dem brief
wird alles gut wäre home köln ev auf der
straße ist man der welt ausgeliefert das
ist ein dauerzustand in eine der home zu
ziehen ist für obdachlose menschen auf
einen wendepunkt in ihrer geschichte von
den 160 seit 2017 gebauten häuschen
konnten bereits 103 weitergegeben werden
weil die bewohner ändern ausziehen
konnten teilweise sogar feste jobs haben
auch weitergegeben weil sie
mega organisation little holmes köln ev
werde auf jeden fall dran denken alles
in der infobox dazu zu verlinken zu den
organisationen das ist richtig positiv
das gibt ein gutes gefühl wenn man
manchmal so tage hat und man denkt aber
heute ist alles scheiße wofür soll ich
den dankbar sein
das ist schon mal ein anfang machen wir
weiter mit türchen nummer 5 band und
anna eine nachhaltige marke für weiche
hände sie haben seit 2017 zu hause
angefangen sehr schön die werde ich aber
natürlich auch verlosen auch wenn sie
schon super ist ich habe zwei handcremes
zu hause die ist für euch
nummer sechs nikolaus
türchen nummer sechs ich glaube ich kann
hier auch alles essen weil ich glaube
alles vegan ist
raumflügen muss mein gott sieht die box
schön aus das bernsteinzimmer pralinen
box mit einer exklusiv für advents am
entwickelten praline und drei weiteren
raffinierten kreationen die muss ich auf
jeden fall probieren
[Applaus]
sorry preisgekrönte tallinn und ich
werde sie hier auf dem boden haselnuss
moca erdnuss karamell mandelkow wie zimt
und
muskatnuss karamell musik probieren
[Musik]
sind die veganen ja tatsächlich ja ich
finde der karamell geschmack ist nicht
so stark also ich hatte jetzt nur
erdnuss geschmeckt nicht haben und
marzipan muss ich probieren
[Musik]
habe noch nie eine praline gegessen
sehr sehr lecker
intensiv also die schachtel macht schon
richtig was her aber vom geschmack her
würde ich jetzt nicht erkennen dass das
die beste praline aller zeiten da bin
ich eher team standard pralinen china 7
wir haben wieder einen brief katar -
sticker set sowie sonstigem in krakow
trauriger sind um verlorene sachen
wiederzubekommen und
nachhaltig bedeutet auch dinge möglich
lange zu verwenden was aber wenn du
einmal das smartphone der reisekoffer
oder den hausschlüssel verloren geht und
man die wertsachen ansetzen muss dieses
ding muss ich euch einmal klären hier
sind qr-code trauring gerne ich ein
klebt es zum beispiel auf meine advent
zum box dann verliere ich meine advents
von box auf dem weg nach köln jemand
finde diese box und sagt da sind qr-code
scanne ich um den ordner zu erreichen
und dann kann man kurz schreiben und
sagen ja schickt mir bitte dahin danke
das ist genial so wie man es bei 7 jetzt
sind wir bei a
14 wird sind
da ist sie unsere 86 cent
cnx basiere alles wasser zucker zimt
ingwer kardamom nelken und chili
biochemischer biota sirup mit dem c-zero
kannst du dir ganz einfach die
aromatischen chai latte zu bereiten es
kommt hin es ist koffein und tein
freilich kannst trinken
intensiv darauf freue ich mich einfach
so ein scheiß ich will mir war
scheiterte bestellt aber meistens ist
der koffein drin und dann kann ich halt
nicht trinken geiles ding und jetzt
kommt unser lieblings kirche natürlichen
naja ein bisschen nachdenken hier den
siechen nummer neun
ist drin erst bei dem online
adventskalender habe ich das
kennengelernt eine deo creme also ich
habe noch die chance online.de creme die
ich echt ganz gerne mal also dieses
verschlossen dann lasse ich nicht
verschlossen da kriegt man sich dann
schon die achseln ein
geo creme mit kokos und zink oder
aluminium aber meile hat gesagt
aluminiums ist gar nicht so schlimm auf
den aktien ich habe immer gedacht
aluminium ist furchtbar weil hat gesagt
es ist ganz okay weil wir ja nominum zu
uns nehmen und m wurde von zwei frauen
enge und monika gegründet das ist bio
kosmetik vegan tierleid frei
klimaneutral ein viertel der gewinne
fließt in öko faire projekte das
allerwichtigste ist ihr und der
nachhaltigkeit auf allen ebenen maximal
voranzubringen zum beispiel mit einem
selbst initiiert im frauenhaus in sambia
ostafrika oder der unterstützung von
projekten gegen recht und es wurde 2920
mit dem nachhaltigkeitspreis
ausgezeichnet sehr sehr cooles projekt
kommt in die verlosung nummer orange
patroullieren eins.de pulver zum
anmischen mit wasser der beute von zoran
tosic flattert mit der post direkt in
deinen briefkasten ohne extra
umverpackung sammle zehn stück schick
sie zurück und erhalte ein all-in was
verschenkt wie die packung was es schon
gibt keiner an vielleicht kennt ihr das
produkt es war das ding des jahres nicht
spieler der löwen ich denke dass das
gründer ehepaar macht sich viele
gedanken in bezug auf nachhaltigkeit so
ist zb das büro klimaneutral und 5
prozent um das projekt gespendet ein
beutel pulver ersetzt 5 plastikflaschen
spart 90% transport emission und ist im
nu zu einem herrlich weichen feinporigen
schaumann gemixte körperhaare gesicht
und hände ist eine seife für alles 900
milliliter bier aus fünf flaschen die
sind bei der hälfte angekommen die
nummer 4 x 3 wissen was einst la crise
wir haben gerade ein richtig schicken
griff gekriegt ein soziales projekt zwei
frauen beim sport machen autonomen
frauenhäuser köln die spenden
ermöglichen uns viel selbst
verteidigungs seminare und vier yoga
kurse anzubieten diese sollen den frauen
helfen zur ruhe zu kommen sich wieder
mit ihrem körper zu verbinden und zu
lernen was sie bei grenzüberschreitenden
verhalten tun können wie sie
handlungsfähig bleiben und angst in wut
umwandeln um sich stärker zu führen
zusätzlich kann das einrichten eines
raumes finanziert werden unter anderem
mit yoga matten sofas musikanlage
tischfußball sehr sehr schön sehr schön
aber auch partner wie kommt man von da
dann wieder los also kirche nummer 13
türchen nummer 13
teams in rom an den uno sitz inne
männergeschmack alle reden von mandeln
muss ich habe das noch nie probiert oder
irgendwas damit gemacht was macht man
damit bionus muss mit suchtfaktor not
enough macht wirklich unvergleichlich
gutes muss merkt euch das ist ja wenn es
als topping für deine bowl feinere dein
curry oder löffel wie echte nuss lover
direkt als snack aus dem glas
jetzt habe ich wieder bock auf kinos
selbst gemacht ist die nummer 14
das ist hier wirklich eine kuriose reise
durch verschiedenste produktes weil ufer
schwimmen für haushalt oder körper dass
könnt ihr denn so tolle waste ufer
schwamm du kannst sie in die
waschmaschine packen du kannst darauf
seine seite ablegen du kannst sie zum
waschen benutzen du kannst alles damit
machen das behalte ich selber nummer 15
uhr total von curri wir haben hier ein
holz dingens bohlen und das hier und ich
habe noch keine das ist ein super foto
theater im holy moly
ritueller
kurssystem schabbing down also sorry
habe mich zwar beruf angestellte aber
excuse me versucht das mal zu lesen
darum ja ein tier aber okay wir müssen
dazu ganz christos lässt auf ihrer reise
durch die hochanden perus entdeckten
camilla und gonzalo die tradition des
emol entities gestimmt auf deine
bedürfnisse mission kräuter schavan
diesen aus verschiedensten zutaten
zusammen dass du deine volle kraft
kommst körper geist und seele sollen so
in einklang gebracht werden ein level
also das ist unabhängig davon ich glaube
das tut man einfach an und macht so
hier drin sind apfelstücke physalis in
leningrad kokosraspeln orangen scheint
natürliches aroma goji beeren
holunderblüten und luca pulver wurde ich
werde den tee und das rauchen
ausprobieren dann berichte ich euch
davon natürlich hier noch mal vier mal
vier ist doch klar natürliches bio
hautpflege öl für gesicht und körper ja
also kunststoff frei ist es nachhaltig
ist es voll nachhaltig superklasse halt
gepresstes granatapfel kernöl mandel
jojoba öl verbinden sich zu einer haut
glätten den schützen denn und
realisieren wenn formel die haut wird
genährt durchfeuchtet und duftet
orientalisch zitrusfrucht das ist sicher
verpackt deswegen werde ich das nicht
aufmachen und
weitergeben 17 wie haben einen schlag
bekommen falls es noch nicht verstanden
habe die umschläge sind immer soziale
projekte die unterstützt werden mit dem
kauf des adventskalenders
auch kann ich nie bewährung ich komme ja
quasi aus dem norden aus hamburg und
hamlet
gott ist es die organisation
treffpunkt wattenmeer seehundstation das
nationalparkhaus wie du ihrem
verschmitzten blick vielleicht schon an
siehst sind seehunde unglaublich
verspielt und neugierig sie haben ihren
eigenen kopf und kommen normalerweise
super allein zurecht leider gibt es aber
auch immer wieder situationen in dem wir
von see und stationen 90 eingreifen ist
also der mensch ist zu viel am schrank
der und nervt die tiere so dass sie den
kontakt verlieren können und auch
wahrscheinlich andere begebenheiten und
dann sind sie verlassen und hollerung
und dann sammeln sie die natürlich ein
und hätten sie auf und dann werden sie
wieder ins meer freigelassen schön schön
das ist toll
18 ein veganes food geschäft wir haben
hier ein rein pflanzliches frische
wachstum habe zwiebel die salatschüssel
oder das laib brot für alles was frisch
bleiben oder abgedeckt werden so
umweltbewusste schon seit einiger zeit
bienenwachs bücherstadt folie die vegane
alternative zu die seite gibt es jetzt
von wachsen
ja stimmt ich habe auch so bienen
wachstum und das ist jetzt die vegane
alternative zum bienenwachs tores
körperwärme wird das tuch flexibel und
das bereits zur benutzung danach
reinigers mit kaltem wasser eventuelle
passamtes spülmittel daß es in der luft
trocknen so hast du eine zirka ein jahr
lang freude daran ich habe noch eine
flasche und mitmachen deckel drauf
weist die marke ich glaube ich hab
typische nummer zehn vergessen natürlich
noch mal zehn vergessen
ich mache mir wirklich noch razzien auch
nachhaltig und fair produzierte premium
links socken von jung fällt am
1 das wären 3 die fühlen sich herzlich
bei langen socken hab ich mal das
problem dass sich um immer zu eng sind
ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwie
übertrieben dicke waden hat es kann aber
gar nicht sein sehr sehr süß sehr schön
und sehr herbstlich sehr weihnachtlich
kann man jetzt nicht kaputt so jetzt
waren wir aber bei türchen nummer 19
eine kooperation mit limbo und
abgrenzung alle drei sorten für ein
belebendes kaffee
kakao ritual cacau 23 zeit schnell
silberkugeln das ist das was hier ist
auch das nicht sollten sie so hier drin
sind so drei kugeln und diese drei
kugeln zerbröseln kugel in der hülle und
lausche ihrem verheißungsvollen es dann
in ihren ehrlich schokolade luft war
bevor du die kakao brösel in warme
pflanzen mich riesen west wo sie die
beiden komponenten charming phishing
getränk vereinigen
das riecht richtig gut wie werde ich
definitiv nicht verlosen die probleme
selber aus 1 8 seite sagt gail
tierchen 20 indien snack lotus pops
knusprige lotus samen pops aus indien
er sieht aus wie ein stück fleisch muss
man auch ein grill vergessen hat
ja das ist ein kräftiger
schmeckt richtig gut als croutons im
salat oder in der suppe wie karton
schmecken auch so geil man als einzige
negative sind was man sagen kann dass es
aus indien kommt weil die reise so lange
es aber ich weiß nicht wieso aber es
schmeckt gleichzeitig herzhafte und süße
tierchen 21 handgemachte duft seife mit
wertvollen ölen limette menthol blaue
tonerde myrrhe und weihrauch lernen
lilian und rosmarin weiß man nicht wie
man dieses yang yang und spricht er
riecht so gut die marke heißt hallo yoko
ich weiß ich hab gesagt habe genug zeit
habe ich liebe feste seife ich habe
immer eine feste seife damen ja
nicht so frisch
ich bin seit mai kauft nur sehr sehr
sehr sehr schöner geruch letzter
umschlag wir sind gut drauf mir geht es
sehr gut ich mache jetzt dieses soziale
projekt auch und wir freuen uns
sehr mit sabine großmutter jetzt drehen
wir helfen
kriminalitätsopfern
also hier wird eine situation
beschrieben dass rohes eltern omas opas
mit dem enkeltrick betrogen werden
ich kann ich kann es ich kann es nicht
verstehen an rentnern in ihrem
lebensabend doch irgendwie deren rente
und was sie sich im leben erspart habt
wegnehmen möchte das finde ich so
hochgradig asoziale genauso es ist
schrecklich es ist absolut schrecklich
wenn es um spenden in höhe von 10.000
euro gehen dann auch wie annegret die
durch solche taten in finanzielle
bedrängnis geraten außerdem setzen wir
die spenden für psychotherapeutische
versorgung ein um die tat verarbeiten
und wieder nach vorne blicken zu können
wir danken dir für die unterstützung und
wünschen die einen und liebe besinnliche
adventszeit es ist echt schrecklich
sowie alleine bei dem bild bald wie kann
man
aber dann klar doch lieber im supermarkt
irgendwie kleine ahnung stück brot oder
was aber doch nicht von der alten frau
was weg und es ist
dieser enkeltrick das hat mich schon was
mach ich schon immer so stark dass
höhere wie er sauer als traurig die
machen mich so füllten diese leute
denken er sei und wütend machen wir
jetzt das 23 türchen auf
ich sehe höhle der löwen
der bruder der mehrweg deckel deine
lieblingstasse wird zum to go becher ob
man mit seiner eigenen tasche so raus
geht aber ich glaube das ist einfach
auch eine gewöhnungssache ich fänds
glaube ich beim ersten mal komisch wenn
ich mit meiner eigenen tasche hat mit
einem deckel ausgehen andererseits ist
es total genial und das ist der deckel
so
ich trinke auf meiner bts kaffeetasse
was schon so spät sah ja dann nehme ich
den kaffee mit
ich rede zur bahn
ich springe es ist ausgelaufen und
betroffen
ich glaube ich sollte den oder einmal in
die spülmaschine schmeißen bei der
schmecken bisher noch klassik nicht nach
plastik aber so neuheit ich nehme ihn
mit auf dem weihnachtsmarkt der ema vor
ihr trinkt beim weihnachtsmarkt glühwein
und bleibt er viel länger dienst war
keiner kann ich was rein kippen der uno
ist auch ein schutz der klub modo kann
also auch sein kannst du sie mit den
club nehmen
uno hat den test bestanden so leute es
ist der 24
es ist heiligabend wir gehen an unseren
adventskalender und finden
good night sleep pilot ist habe ich zwei
mal dieses jahr schon habt in wales
adventskalender und im sommer ins
kalender kissen spray mit natürlichen
ätherischen öle von code rebell
rosenwasser und ätherische öle von
lavendel bitter orange und zimt die
lösen den stress und macht ein ganz
tolles gefühl
das hat einfach für mich den yoga studio
massage wohlfühlt hier bin ich sicher
hoch waren ja tolle produkte ich werde
definitiv nichts nach rechnen darum geht
es hier nicht aber jetzt fragen wir uns
lohnt sich das 119 euro sind eine große
summe spaß natürlich lohnt sich der das
sind tolle produkte sind tolle projekte
die unterstützt werden und ich werde
hier absolut kein schlechtes wort
darüber verlieren weil ich aber auch
wirklich überzeugt bin von dem mann band
zum adventskalender ich bin großer fan
und hier ist noch etwas drin
umweltfreundliche teelichter als 25
geschenkt
[Musik]
ja das ist leider die verpackungen
leider gebrochen aber nur bei ein und
sind wie so kleine tontöpfe für dieses
team ist doch toll wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder ich hoffe euch hat
das hier gefallen und bleibt gesund
bleibt stark weil ich freue mich auf
dieses haus packen mit euch bis dahin